[музика]
дуже важко edged його
якщо презентації романова народом з
маріуполя жердини на публіці куб краще про
мирних
де знаєте щи навряд чи рік штатами і
серж поглинати мені шлюбу та злив нас
тільки манатів козачі запалу
і хоч я купила всю книжку і я не знаю
че буду її читати і чесно кожухи для
мене цінно то сумок її судячи чисту
речей але тут купу
з це просто над українською книжкою
жінку тут 1 українку у сорок третьому
уроці для масового возить дошкуляти чини
восьми ниток вкотре побачить драматично
біографія своєї матері
урок genki маріуполя євгеній іващенко
анна вив і кума залі жадібного вірного
місяця тут ніж а ось їх народи всі
військові обох наташа в один по військовий
період війни хоче знати і я хто devesa
виду волосся
мільйони ви біля вгамовувати karate концерни
пит наступство реміс
не руди на гусей украй вигляд дусі
користувалася чутками та контингентом
імпорту ван їх раббі прапорець тут
зручності ножа хев нацистського режиму та
багато від просто особисто не частка українців
і росіян викрадених дошкуляти шини
направив свій у роботи з літературно
зростання ж porsche у тому donna давно
крим імені примарно листі ненсі нічого
простий матюка знала на тягу було до
сид рокки в колота джини ласо можу пса
цього fave балансі вона прожила лише e36
років забув і не кисть руки поріг і
громадян sky війни шісток
катастрофічного голодомору вас рср рук і
інший світловий до націонал-соціалізму
дзвінок від rapala у м'ясорубку 2 диктатур
спочатку сталінську в Україні а шляхом
нацистську не матч і не стискала важко
ще вдалося усвідомити і самі листи ниток
ок російську блискавок на пірс уроки у
кого ені не матчі не париже це
очевидно з мусалу і вріжте взятий за
перо
в кому мені жити вона тягни в один було
знає і сліди матері у довоєнного
маріуполі і раб там якщо до вважали пітьма
рних гармати
літні ночі 2013 року
я була і їм я то зізнайся в російській
інтернеті та покроково машина видала
результат за допомогою людей у ​​приазов'ї
від віконця евіта москві і вдалося
реконструювати та занапащений sweet
малюка своєї батьківщини а is he дно і
україни до друга і світлове поки що лиж і
для німецької публіки в темпі зміниться на
виключаючи ще книжку перекладати
російську біографічний роман ж від
рима у знанні його мине на головну
премію лейпцизького ярмарку